a while back we found out that Donald
Trump's son-in-law and senior advisor
Jared Kushner had a meeting with Russian
ambassador Sergei kis Lee act during
Donald Trump's transition period and
then a couple weeks ago we discovered
that Kushner also had another meeting
with Russian National Bank official
Sergei Gourcuff which had previously
been undisclosed the White House was
covering it up and we did a segment on
that the picture is getting even worse
now in terms of Jared Kushner's
connections to Russia and his total lack
of transparency about it we've now
learned that Jared Kushner has actually
been hiding dozens of other meetings
with Russia in fact he even chose not to
report them when he was applying for
top-secret security clearance at the
White House when he began working for
Donald Trump which is sort of in an of
itself bordering on breaking
anti-nepotism laws but that's sort of
another story he's not a blood relative
of Donald Trump pushers lawyer is saying
that he didn't reveal the meetings
because he forgot about them there are
some really forgetful people who are
doing work or were doing work for Donald
Trump and their difficulty to remember
has focused around meetings they had
with Russians hasn't it yeah maybe these
Russian officials and oligarchs are just
incredibly boring because yeah you
remember Michael Flynn Trump's disgraced
former national security adviser he
forgot whether or not he had discussed
sanctions with Sir Jake is Leo yeah and
then Jeff Sessions forgot about the
meetings all together and then
remembered them but not all of them nor
what was discussed inside as far as
Kushner is concerned when you apply for
top-level security clearance with the
federal government this is a credential
that gives you access to the country's
most sensitive important classified
information you're required to disclose
all encounters you've had with foreign
government officials over the prior
seven years it's a pretty reasonable
rule kushner concealed dozens of
meetings including other meetings with
Russian ambassador Sergey kis lyac
Russian oligarchs Sergei Gore qov it's
clear why Kushner wouldn't want the
public to know about those meetings but
when you tell the government about me
you've had in order to get a security
clearance the public isn't necessarily
going to find out in this case we did so
maybe Kushner was onto something but
there clearly are reasons that he didn't
even want the intelligence community to
know about these meetings your answers
on the sf-86 forum that's what you fill
out to get a federal security clearance
they're completely confidential they're
not public record they're not even
accessible through Freedom of
Information Act requests and on a legal
level Kushner should lose his security
clearance for lying about these meetings
and maybe even face penalties but in
terms of the ethics and the optics once
again lying about contact with Russia
Donald Trump should dismiss Kushner from
the White House altogether since we now
know that we have a top-level adviser
lying about dozens of meetings with a
foreign adversary in order to get access
to US secret information will never
happen though right I mean Kushner he's
four he's a golden boy in this
administration yeah because he's not
only Trump's advisor he's also his own
son-in-law and it's hard to kick out
your own family you can lose the
security clearance for a lot less and in
how many legal domains would the
explanation of I forgot excuse the lies
you're pulled over by a cop for speeding
and you say forgot about the speed limit
oh whether you forgot oh okay right
you're audited by the IRS you say I just
totally forgot to pay taxes on a hundred
thousand dollars worth of income
although actually sometimes with the IRS
if you convince them that you weren't
acting maliciously you just have to make
up the missed tax maybe that's not the
best example but the speeding one I
think is a solid one because by saying
you forgot that kind of allows you to
get out of the situation without lying
because those are your only two options
at that point let alone the fact that
Jared Kushner should not even be in the
picture for getting a top secret
security clearance in the first place
but the big picture is it continues
before any scandal gets its due
attention from the public it's
overshadowed by the next scandal the
public can't keep up with it all and
thus we are unable to fully react to
what would be alone major scandals
during other presidencies the Senate
Intelligence Committee is going to be
questioning Jared Kushner about the
meetings and an upcoming hearing but you
know at this point the way things are
going
knows if that will even make news we'll
be covering it but I don't know if it
will make news